Acum că am trecut prin toate elementele VQE, hai să
rezumăm ce am învățat și să vedem cum le execută un calculator cuantic.
Începem cu starea de referință aleasă inteligent, circuit parametrizat,
alegerea inițială a parametrilor și un Hamiltonian.
Le trimitem calculatorului nostru cuantic.
Înainte ca Hamiltonianul să poată fi executat pe starea ansatz,
trebuie să facem o preprocesare clasică a circuit-ului
pentru a-l face lizibil de hardware-ul cuantic, într-un proces numit transpilation.
E important și să profităm la maximum
de arhitectura qubit-urilor din hardware-ul real, ca să obținem cele mai bune rezultate.
Aceste procese sunt adesea gestionate automat, astfel încât noi să nu
trebuiască să cunoaștem explicit conectivitatea qubit-urilor,
fidelitățile gate-urilor și altele.
Acum sarcina este să măsurăm starea rezultată
și să estimăm valoarea de așteptare, care va fi în continuare
optimizată de un optimizator clasic.
Această măsurătoare se realizează prin rotirea bazei de măsurare
și apoi combinând rezultatele măsurătorilor pentru a obține valoarea de așteptare.
Acest rezultat parametrizat este apoi transmis
optimizatorului clasic, care găsește noi parametri pentru stare.
Apoi procesul se repetă.
O preprocesare clasică creează un nou circuit parametrizat
și aplicăm același Hamiltonian ca înainte.
De remarcat că în întregul proces VQE schimbăm doar stările
prin parametri care se apropie din ce în ce mai mult de starea fundamentală.
Repetăm asta până când suntem mulțumiți de rezultat.
Și cam atât.
Numele meu este Victoria Lipinska și acesta a fost un curs de variational quantum eigensolver.